With five columns right off the bat,
we know that we can't do four columns evenly.
So this can't be right.
With eight columns, it's impossible to have three evenly spaced columns.
So we know that eight columns isn't right.
With 12 columns, we know that 2, 3, and 4 all divide into 12 evenly.
Meaning that we can have two even columns, three even columns or
four even columns on the screen.
So this seems like a pretty good answer.
But let's think about 20.
With 20 columns, 3 doesn't divide into 20 evenly.
So we know that we can't do three even columns on the screen.
Also, you'll notice that people need to be able to read things.
And if a column is one 20th of the screen, it's going to be pretty tiny and
that's going to be hard to see.
So, I can't imagine us ever needing a column that small.
This means that the correct answer is 12 columns.
And in fact, most of the grid systems,
if not all of the grids systems that you'll see today use 12 columns.